hi
today we're going to solve a puzzle
called the triangle area puzzle
what we have is
four different triangles
where the hypotenuse is three
and the length of one leg is one unit
longer than the other
the question is what's the area of a
single triangle
i'm going to give you a moment to solve
this you can pause the video and take
your time
once you're ready
you can keep playing
the answer to this puzzle
is that the area of a single triangle is
two
the more interesting part is how we can
arrive at the answer
one way you can solve this is you can
work algebraically
this is the long way to solve the
problem
the steps involved are you would label
the two legs of the triangle as a and b
you can then set up a system of
equations
one equation will be that a is equal to
b plus one because we know one of the
legs is one unit longer than the other
the other equation is that a squared
plus b squared equals c squared the
hypotenuse squared
in this case three squared by the
pythagorean theorem
we now have two equations
for two unknown variables which means we
can solve for a and b
and then the final step would be to find
the area of a single triangle which is
one half a times b
this is a rather long and messy way to
solve this problem i'm actually not
going to go through the algebra
if you do you'll find out the answer is
two
however i want to point out a much more
elegant way to solve this problem which
is geometric
so what we're going to do we start out
with these same four triangles and we
can do a little neat trick where we
rearrange the triangles as follows we're
going to move one up
this one to the side and shift this one
over
now we've noticed something neat we
basically have
a big square which has
a side 3 and we have the four triangles
and we have a small square
from this we can figure out the answer
we know that the area of the big square
is equal to the area of the four
triangles plus the area of the small
square
we can solve the area of the big square
three squared
must be equal to one squared plus the
area of the four triangles
that means the area of the four
triangles must equal eight and the area
of a single triangle is two
i hope you enjoyed this puzzle please
subscribe to the channel and you can
also follow me on mind your decisions
on my blog i post weekly puzzles on
monday
there are also weekly game three posts
on tuesday
and that's my
twitter at preshtalwalker thanks for
watching